hello believe nation so I find it
interesting that two of the people that
I have on the wall behind me are both
considering running for president of the
United States in the future election the
first Howard Schultz directly behind me
is the CEO and founder of starbucks and
a second far on the wall there mr. Kanye
West so I want to play a clip from each
of them and then get your thoughts he is
perhaps the most outspoken leader in
corporate America Starbucks CEO Howard
Schultz has been vocal about his stance
on guns gay rights race relations and
money in politics so every time I
interview Howard I ask him one question
10 times I've asked maybe probably more
than that so make sure make it 11 okay
will you ever run for president Howard
you know I think as we have discussed
this many times my own life experience
has given me a unique perspective on the
plight of working class American people
and the position and the platform i have
had at starbucks has given me the voice
and the opportunity to do many things
that i don't think i could have ever
done as an elected official having said
that on I'm a young man as a lot of time
in the future of the country and what I
might I might not do I would never say
never but this is not the right time you
have said no previously this is the
first time I've heard you say I'm a
young man
hero alright I've been rayban reminded
by friends of mine who heard me say that
this morning that I'm no longer that
young so well we'll have to see how that
goes regardless of your political
persuasion I think everyone in this room
with probably a hundred percent
participation can agree that what we
have witnessed over the last year is
inconsistent with the values and guiding
principles of the promise of our country
we can also agree that our parents and
our grandparents would be embarrassed to
see what we have witnessed and yet as
private citizens we are watching and
observing and actually being bystanders
and allowing us to go on I travel
perhaps more than any other CEO in the
world internationally and specifically
to China people cannot believe what is
going on in this country but what I
would what I would submit is even though
the political season has highlighted all
of this this is nothing new what we're
witnessing with vitriol and the hatred
and the device of this is a
manifestation of what has gone on the
last twenty and thirty years and that is
the lack of truth and authenticity of
people who are elected officials in
Washington we as private citizens must
recognize that the democracy of this
country that people fought so hard for
and sacrifice so much for is something
that we must embrace and we must
participate and whether or not we're
voting for president this year or the
next four years it's the decisions we
make every day it's local politics its
regional politics and we must
participate in we must vote and we must
get control of the direction of the
country and not wait for Washington not
blame Washington and recognized as we've
launched today with this new original
content series quote up standards that
there are thousands of Americans
ordinary people doing extraordinary
things these stories must be told and it
must be catalytic and not just look at
Washington as a problem and look at the
American people and say we can solve
things
in our own communities are these the
people Howard that changed your answer
to my question about Willie run for
president from no 2 i'm serious from no
2 i'm a young man you always come back
to them you know i think the last year
the concern I have about the future the
country has made me think about a lot of
things I've been conflicted bro I just
wanted people to like me more
both bro and yes as you probably could
have guessed by this moment I have
decided in 2020 to run for president
so I have my own thoughts on Howard
Schultz vs Kanye that ended up becoming
the political matchup I haven't gone
into the political territory much or
ever I don't think on this channel we
featured politicians from both sides of
the spectrum because I feel like you can
learn from everybody whether they're
Republican or Democrat or independent
but I'm curious what do you guys think
who would you vote for Howard Schultz
are Kanye West if that was the ticket
have a little bit of fun don't spread a
lot of hate guys just have a little bit
of fun who would you vote for that was a
twenty20 ticket Howard Schultz or Kanye
West leave it down the comments below
super curious to find out thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon